[Music]  chad is in augusta georgia hi chad how  are you  good sir how you all doing better than  we deserve man what's up  oh yeah i'm just calling and i'm uh a  i have a  mortgage just about ready to pay at all  good but i'm a real estate agent and you  know with a real estate agent you got to  kind of go get it i love going to get it  but it's a big chunk  and i'm just like i think i'm there but  i'm looking for i guess maybe a final  confirmation with retirement that i have  what's in place to pay it off i've been  a fan of yours for probably 20 years and  i've hit bumps along the way to to get  my house paid off and now i'm at a  position so what do you want  how much cash do you have  211.  good lord pay it off today what are you  doing  paying off today you don't need to think  about it  jacob's in fort worth hey jacob